so the big news that's been happening
all week that the the left seems to be
latching onto and is a really good
example of anarcho tyranny is uh this
dude Jordan Neely who died after he was
choked and he was subdued and then
choked on the train and we got this new
story from the New York Post and 9-1-1
flooded with calls including reports of
a gun while Jordan nearly was fatally
choked on train they say a total of five
emergency calls were made over four
minute span just before 2 30 P.M Monday
when now identified 24 year old Daniel
Penny held kneeling a choke on the floor
of the Northbound F train the first call
came in at 226 was reporting a physical
fight on the subway followed by another
one minute later someone reporting on
the train threatening writers so it
sounds like this guy nearly had already
attacked people then was threatening
people because
you can't have one call come in and then
a call come in after
right so it's so people are saying the
original story was that Neely was
threatening people and then he got
subdued sounds like he attacked people
then when it stopped went on to threaten
people and then later a third caller uh
uh said he was armed with a knife or a
gun
it was unclear whom the callers
referring to though Nelly Neely or penny
so we don't know for sure but I really
don't think they're talking about the
three men who subdued this guy now
what's end up what's ended up happening
is I think I have a tweet from AOC she
tweets I have yet to hear a real
explanation from any official hesitating
to condemn the killing of Jordan Neely
about what makes condemning this
violence so complicated it's not
complicated there's nothing that here's
I'll tell you this AOC make it easy for
you I condemn Jordan Neely's violence I
condemn your soft on crime policies that
resulted in 25 people last year being
shoved in front of trains with two of
them dying I condemn you and your
actions and I commend the man the men
who's tried stopping this violent man
and I am sad that Jordan nearly lost his
life was that so difficult
I hand it to you panel
I mean this is also something we're
seeing a lot in my city of Vancouver
first of all I think public transport is
very quickly becoming a human rights
violation we just had an Isis stabbing
where a teenager had his throat slit on
the subway another uh gentleman killed I
probably a lot of you probably saw the
Starbucks stabbing in Vancouver what no
you didn't see it so it was always
footage some guy was fatally stabbed in
front of his toddler because he asked
the guy to stop vaping and it was
actually with a religious knife from a
Sikh gentleman I think
um broad daylight in Vancouver and it's
all of these people this was like two
three weeks ago whoa
um it's a whole lot of people with
mental health issues that keep being
released on the street 40 individuals
this was last year committed over 3 000
crimes in one year in Vancouver and they
can't figure it out they can't figure
out what to do you give that list of 40
people to a toddler and they can tell
you what to do with it put them in jail
put them in jail if they have committed
oh I did see this right I did see this
story I did not realize that's what had
what had caused it yeah I just saw the
video's like whoa that guy got stabbed
yo and he's watching as the dude bleeds
out yeah he asked him but none of that's
ever condemned right the fact that we
live in a culture that doesn't see this
is out of the ordinary but loses its
mind when somebody tries to defend
themselves is never condemned by any of
these political leaders who claim to
care so much about human life no that's
because they're evil yeah so it's like
it's like listen like
I'll use traditional comic book and
cartoon lore the villain is the one like
the Joker releasing the inmates from
prison and then laughing as the inmates
terrorize people and then when the super
Evolution man when the superhero stops
the criminals they go no they get mad
that it's happening that's literally
what we're seeing ocasio-cortez is a
comic book villain she is Lex Luthor she
pretends to be of the people they all
celebrate her that's quite literally
what Lex Luthor represented he was the
perfect villain for Superman because he
didn't have superpowers he controlled
social Society through corporations and
wealth and means AOC is certainly not
extremely wealthy but she uses her
influence to defend the the criminals
and condemn the victims she lied about
January 6 and she's trying to condemn
innocent people now politicians need to
be forced to take the subway every day
if they have an opinion like that if
they think that he was the victim in
this situation obviously I think no one
should have been put in this situation
everyone was the victim of an extremely
broken system yeah like but but in the
moment the man who is threatening people
is the perpetrator yeah I don't care if
you're like but he's mentally ill so
what well he never should have been out
there running around on the bus
threatening people in the first place
institutions for these people exactly
there needs to be institutions for these
people we need to have real Frank
conversations about what has to be done
about the decline of mental health in
the United States that aren't just let's
say nice platitudes and throw money at a
system that isn't going to actually do
anything and especially when you have
political leaders like AOC who want for
there to be National Mass public transit
from one side of the nation to the other
with these massive Railways and they're
not even doing anything to ensure that
the mass transit in their own cities are
are safe for people or is safe for
people it's like okay now you want this
to be the only option people have on a
national scale you want to start to
slowly do away with highways and ensure
that the only way people can get across
the country is by riding these Railways
when the railways in your city are
extremely dangerous and you're not doing
anything to make the I'm safe I think
one thing that could be done is that we
could do some sort of prison reform
where we start putting webcams in
prisons for inmates that are supervised
and allow them to communicate with
therapists and family so we really do
turn it into a sort of
um I don't know a place where people can
actually become better as opposed to
just retribution and Vengeance and we
want them we don't want people to suffer
in prison we want them to become better
humans but I can take it one step
further I I just I realized this the
other day very very simple solution if
you break the law you are uh we
forcefully give you the meta the the
neuralink implant and then plug you in
and delete from your brain criminality
dude no joke that is something that
could happen they they I think it's like
A Clockwork Orange yeah they were
talking about neural networks early on
when they were talking about Elon was
talking about neural net that you could
dampen emotional receptors with it I
think I think that they were actually
talking about that the same we just we
just put like the neural link thing on
them and then if they ever are about to
commit a crime it just slows down their
motor functions until they stop and then
the opportunity stops and then they can
only resume if they in their mind reject
what the other thing is so you'll have
some dude who wants to go out and commit
crimes and it'll start to slow down and
people go well help that man there's
something wrong I'll go try to comfort
him and then he'll reach in and take
their wallet a simple simple thing is
the the the device will start going this
man is experiencing criminal desires
this man is experiencing criminal
desires and that's like steer clear stay
away stay away stay away yeah it just
broadcasts your thoughts really loudly
all the time every disaster that's so
horrible everyone just has their
thoughts shouted from a speaker at all
times you know what's Wild to me is like
when you're younger and you look at
criminality you think it's like a super
big deal like oh my gosh your life is
going to be over if you commit a crime
like this is insane and then you get
older and I I was um I was actually
assaulted in a grocery store a few years
ago some guy grabbed my butt but he
grabbed the wrong butt I'll tell you
right now because I sent him straight to
jail wow but it turns out he was on bail
like that week he had just gotten out of
jail for serial assault had grabbed four
other women in the shops that morning
none of them wanted to come to court but
I was willing to I was like yeah I'll
put forward a statement and take the
CCTV footage and everything but it's
like wild to me that he knows mere days
after getting out of jail on on bail
he's like let's go get back on the
streets
look this is another thing that often
goes unacknowledged but sex criminals
have that one of the highest rates of
recidivism if not the highest rate so
you can't just let them out on bail
yeah we got to put the neuraling thing
in them that's what I'm saying is how
did you get that guy put away what was
your process I just I called the police
after and I was like hey this happened
oh and here's another thing like a bunch
of people watched it happen and they all
just kind of froze everyone freezes when
there's something like criminal it's
like in that Starbucks
video the guy in the background just
sitting there drinking his coffee yep or
the guy on the phone being like
like y'all and I don't do it there
because where the guys you see the one
where the guy got shot on camera
don't you guys remember the Simpsons
when Mr Burns got shot by Maggie and you
just spoiled spoiler alert he explains
that like after he got shot he found
only lollygaggers and it's like Jimbo
going like whoa just like pointing at
him as he's like dying that's right
Simpson's predicted all this yeah I
don't want a society where people just
stand by and watch people get violently
assaulted but yeah like to create a
system where people are afraid to
intercede because they might become
arrested for hurting some criminal this
is what I was thinking I'm like no one
well first of all there were a lot of
women there uh so they don't want to go
up against a man unless they have guns
and no one has guns outside of America
yeah
then there's also the fact that yeah if
you're a man and you actually win that
fight and you do the heroic thing you're
taught to do as a child you save the
woman in distress whatever goodbye life
like you're going to jail like this dude
they won't be as kind to you right
they're not going to let you out of
prison they're going to throw the book
at you so and even if you didn't
actually do anything that rises to the
level of a crime so here's a great story
that many people in the audience May
unfortunately not have heard of Mark
Houck over a year ago was protesting
outside of an abortion clinic and he was
just there praying with his son and
every time he went there and prayed
there was an older man who would shout
obscenities and disgusting things at his
son and so finally one day this old man
comes over to him and starts approaching
his son to assault him and Mark Houck
pushes the old man away the Soros funded
prosecutor in that area said there's
nothing to charge this man with there's
literally nothing to charge this man
with there's no case here but a year
later the FBI in doj where the doj
decides to charge him the FBI raids his
house us and they try to get him
convicted with a penalty that would
result in him going to prison for 11
years for pushing a guy for pushing a
guy yeah they were saying it was a
violation of the face act and again the
Soros funded prosecutor in his area a
year earlier said there was no case
there was nothing to follow but because
he has the wrong political values
because he was protesting abortion we
should lock him up and throw away the
key take a look we have mercy for people
who are violent criminals and let them
back out under the street to harm
everybody else thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time